da ist eine bombe war sehr cremig haben
wir gut mit dem boden gefroren ich zwar
nicht mit diesem und auf 66 boden so gut
aus
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es ein
lieblingsrezept bzw nicht ihr
lieblingsrezept aber einfach ein
lieblingsrezept was ihr immer gerne
backt und macht wenn es mal schnell
gehen soll und ist oft escape wenn man
die ruhezeit nämlich außer acht lässt
braucht ihr summa summarum nur so 2025
richtig lange wir starten jetzt direkt
mit dem boden in dem dafür einfach
butterkekse oder ich habe dann tipp für
euch möchte ein bisschen karamell kekse
noch mit ein und achtet einfach darauf
dass die grammer ag bestimmt ich
schreibe euch ja alle ganz genommen
angaben hier unten infobox und da steht
einfach wie viel gramm kekse ihr braucht
unternimmt einfach trockene kekse und
ich mache eben so dass ich so ein anteil
an karamell kriegs einfach dazu mobile
weiß geschmack ist einfach total lecker
findet und dazu geben wir dann noch
zerlassene butter und das ist im prinzip
schon unser boden ich sage ja dieses
rezept ist ja sehr schnell so und den
boden füllen wir dann ein in unseren
back rahmen den habe ich hier schon auf
mein backblech gestellt
warum hast du dann das gewicht weil also
man könnte auch nur butterkekse nehmen
aber ich finde werden anteilig weitere
jahren hast du das war dass die gefehlt
haben
ich kann mich erinnern dass sagen ich
muss gucken also dass fast keine
gedanken denn fast richtig ja und ich
vor zwei jahren sondern ich glaube vor
vier fünf jahren hat mir mal so eine
skate gemacht da fehlt mir butterkeks
und ich habe mit löffelbiskuits
aufgefüllt wenigstens war nicht
aufgepasst und gutes gedächtnis wir
haben 29
33 jährige okay ich wollte den kurzen
auftritt haben ein cameo auftritt
kämpfen so also die botschaft ist die
eigenmarke von kaufland die cara möglich
so gibt es auch bei kaufland er findet
dort eigentlich alles was man zum backen
braucht so ich will das jetzt hier ein
und dann werde ich das einfach so ein
bisschen glatt andrücken
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier schon in
magerquark in eine große schüssel
gegeben ihr braucht eigentlich noch
nicht meine maschine könnte das auch mit
einem schneebesen verriet ich habe halt
einfach das handrührgerät oder inhalt
auch die küchenmaschine das geht auch so
den ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze weil es
geht wirklich sehr schnell ich habe
jetzt hier zum quark noch etwas
frischkäse gegeben ihr könnt eigentlich
rein theoretisch auch den frisch dieser
anteil komplett durch quark ersetzen bei
diesem rezept ist man wirklich sehr
variabel und dann brauchen wir noch
milch und sahne gebe ich gleich direkt
dazu zusammen mit den eiern und dann
fehlt im prinzip nur noch süße also
zucker geschmackvoll in der extrakt
nämlich da und ein bisschen öl und das
machen wir einfach nur alles miteinander
[Musik]
so etwas habe ich wirklich nur 30 40
sekunden miteinander verrührt damit sich
alles miteinander verbindet und jetzt
gebe ich ihm auch schon auf den keks
boden übrigens habe ich den bug rahm
eingestellt auf jetzt habe ich auch
schon wieder vergessen
26 x 24 cm und das wird jetzt gebacken
auf jeden fall vorher schon erwähnt ganz
wichtig dass du dass ihr das beachtet
war letztens hat mir auch eine
zuschauerin geschrieben hast nicht
funktioniert dann sind wir auf
fehlersuche man setzt sich
herausgestellt dass der ofen einfach
dann eingeschaltet wurde als der kuchen
reinkam so und der braucht dann 40
minuten und dann weist ihn bitte
vollständig auskühlen ich mache das so
dass ich einfach am nächsten tag weiter
machen aber ich hab grad die zeit
ansonsten dass das gerne drei vier
stunden lang komplett auskühlen bevor
mit der frühschicht weitermachen bis
nachher
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der nächste tag das ist
der cheesecake der sieht super aus 1 2
minimale risse ich bin happy ihr könnt
den auch gerne im oft einfach mit so
einer spalte offen einfach ausklingen
lassen als hätte nicht auch nicht im
kühlschrank dort muss wirst du hast gute
gute eine gute frage dass wörz ist
youtube einfach die tür auf haben und
irgendwas dazwischen schieben entweder
aus holz oder aus was sie zu beständigen
so wie man jetzt den guss und dafür habe
ich jetzt ja einfach meine hochland
fahne ich hab da eine küchenwaage
drunter und wiegt jetzt einfach ab ich
hab' ich will mal die ganz genaue
mengenangaben unten in die infobox genau
wie ich das jetzt einfach das sind
übrigens tiefgekühlte hier mehr das ist
nämlich ganz praktisch außerhalb der
saison die werden ihre ernte ist richtig
gefreut außerhalb der saison da immer
die fehlbare benutzen und da mag ich
einfach wasser dazu und speisestärke ihr
könnt gerne auch mal gucken ob ich die
himbeere süß gemüt sind falls nicht
gerne ein bisschen zucker dazugeben und
dann wird das ganze schön filmchen frei
verrührt und ein mal aufgekocht und
anschließend werde ich auch noch
pürieren
[Musik]
denn im bus ist jetzt fertig ich habe
hier noch stückchen drin ich persönlich
mag dass es gibt auch menschen gedanken
dieses stückchen den himbeeren die
passiere ich noch mal also das wünschen
ja
doch man kann die ruhig über durch sein
haar sie geben uns passieren dann
beachtet aber auch dass sie weniger von
dem bus habt dann ist die schicht
vielleicht ein bisschen dünner ist aber
auch nicht schlimm so und jetzt mache
folgen das anders wollte ich euch noch
zeigen damit ihr euch nicht wonach es
ist ganz normal dass ein bisschen butter
austritt das ist ganz normal dass ich
keine sorge machen also ist auch das
einzige was mir ausgetreten ist aber
wenn jetzt weniger mutter nehmen dann
ist die masse also die klicks zu
krümelig und wir brauchen genau diese
mutter menge diese butter menge sagt und
letzte folge mit der gestik ist ja so
ein bisschen geschrumpft das ist ganz
normal mit einfach hier den bug raum und
macht ihr noch mal so ein bisschen enger
da dran und dann gehe ich einfach nur
den im bewusst drauf und dann streiche
ich den club da muss dann nur noch fest
während es dauert zehn minuten und dann
können auch scheint es testen das war's
schon
[Musik]
was ist er für ein
kunstwerk bei
fragen
ja dann manchmal gespannt
anspruchsvoller hamza ist richtig feuer
also ist das gerade über schokolade gab
es wirklich heißt eigentlich wollte noch
sagen ich bin richtig stolz doch nicht
gewesen das ist ja himbeer gekocht und
püriert und so weiter mit einem weißen
oberteil grad sogar noch ohne schützen
und ich habe nicht ich habe mich einfach
auf mein weißes oberteil gehabt nicht
einfach ich hoffe das geht und man kann
mit schokolade endlich das ist heftig in
weiteren ländern ist es macht mir
geworden ich habe übrigens noch
dekoriert mit zartbitterschokolade peter
weiß doch gar nicht weder schokolade und
dann einfach nur so ja ich wollte ich
dass ich weiß ich glaube nimmt aber weil
ich jetzt das bitter aber ganz ehrlich
ich finde eine abstimmung geht sind sie
die schwarze schokolade schön ich finde
das mit weißer schaum ihr kommentare
kinder so kommentar schreiben ab ob das
us-team schwarzer hat das machen bevor
wir zu viel quatschen okay
ist eine bombe das ist man so eine
rezeptur alle komponenten nimmt die
direkt alle waren da brauchte ich war
nämlich mit diesem unglaublichen keks
boden so gut aus haben mehr große hier
glaube ich nicht also zwischen klicks
genau jammeh glück auf das ist so ein
kuchen den markt jeder ich sage das auch
hin und wieder mal es gibt auch
spezielle kuchen das ist für den einen
oder anderen damit sich der sagen aber
ich glaube den machen jeder und sehr
cremig haben mit dem boden die vorgaben
perfekt wie schön so ein so ein kleiner
frühsommer grüße mal gucken
ja
aber fröhlich ist so ist so ein bisschen
winter aber ich meine so kurz vor sorgen
zwischen frühling und sommer so kurz
versuchen
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann hinterlasst einen daumen nach oben
und
[Musik]
die
sache noch zum saubermachen
[Musik]